you're using old people as a measuring  stick for the current Society it doesn't  correlate so it doesn't it doesn't work  bro and like again he's saying oh don't  email because you're saying I've got  money but you do have money though  we talking about bro in the UK the the  energy prices have gone up considerably  house prices have gone up considerably  it's not easy bro  do you know what I'm saying like I  really can't stand these people that act  like everybody's balling we're not all  living some uh rock star life it's  unrealistic bars yeah and like at the  end of the day he's talking about oh  yeah this is an honor what do you mean  bro the woman is a stranger bro